joining us now for the latest on the
outbreak and possible treatments is CBS
News medical contributor dr. David agus
he joins us from Los Angeles David good
morning morning Dana let me start with
that idea of the drugs that we have
heard about chloroquine specifically
this anti-malarial drug we've heard
there's anecdotal evidence that it may
work for those of us who aren't doctors
what does that mean so remember there's
chloroquine and there's
hydroxychloroquine which is a much safer
version so hydroxychloroquine is on the
market it was FDA approved over the last
30 years for both arthritis and malaria
and autoimmune diseases and there is
real data that it works it's not
randomized controlled trials but
individual patients viral load has come
down and the mechanism in the test tube
seems to be similar and so because of
that doctors are using it across the
country because we can write a
prescription for it we call it off-label
use you'll see announced early next week
is there'll be a national database
following patients on these drugs and
their response to the thing so we can
actually collect data that doctor felt
she was referring to but doctor if
you're writing prescriptions for those
drugs right now how do you know the
dosage is right it's a great question
we're using drug dosages that others
have used both in Asia and here I've
probably written several dozen I have
several dozen patients who are on it the
biggest problem we face is that in
California now it takes about a week to
get a test result back and with these
drugs the earlier you treat the better
the outcome so I'm many times treating
before the result comes back because I
want to get the best outcome for the
patient doctor as people are obviously
concerned with drugs that may work also
concerned with testing where do we stand
now in this idea that so many people
want to be able to get tested if they
feel the need is there we're not close
to the testing infrastructure in this
country unfortunately at major centers
in New York LA San Francisco's there are
long long lines we're still restricted
in California to testing people who are
symptomatic or who you know will make a
clinical change that this doctor will
make a decision based on the result we
are not testing everybody we'd
have that infrastructure and again it
takes days to get a test result back so
we now are having more tests the problem
is the infrastructure to run the tests
wasn't there is trying to be built up
dr. on the shortages taking place right
now ventilators and mess heard from a
nurse in ICU yesterday she says she's
been given one n95 mask expected to use
that all day long course doctors and
nurses have to eat and drink during
their shifts and then put it back in a
paper bag and use it again the next day
how big a deal is the shortage of masks
how confident are you we can get more of
them how confident are you we can get
more ventilators listen all of those are
horrible I went to the hospital
yesterday I walked by at least 20 cars
with doctors sleeping in the cars their
family members and they didn't want to
affect their family and my business so
they're not going home at night they're
sleeping in their cars every night
because they know they're going to get
infected and they don't want to spread
it to others we don't have supplies on
the front line we don't have ventilators
respiratory technicians those are the
ones who run the ventilators they're
also starting to get the virus and if we
have nobody to run the ventilators it
doesn't matter how many we have this is
a war and we're missing the supplies we
need in this war we sorely need reef
resources at the frontlines and we need
to start to giving drugs to people on
the frontline who've been exposed it's
called post exposure prophylaxis if you
give a drug right after that it been
exposed with HIV or influenza you can
actually block the virus the hope is we
can do the same thing here so doctors
and nurses and other health professors
on the frontline aren't going down there
certainly are people who have been
exposed and show no symptoms these
asymptomatic people how likely is it
that they are also then giving the
disease to other people it may never
show any symptoms it's one of the
biggest issues with this virus is that
people can spread the disease when
they're asymptomatic we don't exactly
know how long there's no test for
infectiousness if you will and so the
disease is spreading and unknowingly
someone can have it for a couple of days
go somewhere and spread it which is why
social distancing staying at home in the
state of California we're not leaving
the house
and that is the way to stop it and you
know the interesting part is that it
takes seven to ten days after
implementation of these drastic measures
to see the benefits so this happened
midweek the hope is toward the end of
next week we start to see a significant
decline in the number of cases I'm
hopeful America is stepping up we are
all doing the right thing and we will
see the benefits combine that with the
drugs that we're now using and I think
we're gonna see a shift going from
defense to offense against this virus
alright dr. David agus thank you very
much for your expertise appreciate it